one of my favorite people from cbs
sports and i met her many many many
moons ago when uh i first started an nfl
network and she was spending all those
years in the front office of the raiders
organization she is amy trask back here
on the richard show how are you amy
i am well thank you for having me it is
such a treat to join you but let's not
tell anyone how many years ago that was
when we met okay you know what as soon
as they came out of my mouth i'm like oh
man are you going to hear it from me
but it's true we go way back i mean
that's just the only way i can actually
put it and uh i'm cherished
i'm honored to have known you so many
years i i you know i i've known you so
long that uh you were standing right
next to al davis when he gave me grief
for where the championship team from the
la raiders landed on the top 50 uh
all-time list uh super bowl champions
and i'm like i have nothing that i had
nothing to do with this well i don't
know if you remember that i was giggling
when he was doing that but i was
actually looking at you for a lifeline
amy sorry about that
guys he came up to me at an owner's
meeting like complaining like like any
fan would like who's who's deciding
where the uh the la raiders were one of
the greatest champions of all time and
i'm like i don't do any i'm just the
host oh you know
[Laughter]
so uh i could not help but notice your
your article for the athletic and your
your your opinion of what the jaguars
should do with urban meyer i give you
the floor to put it into words uh for
this audience right now well i did have
a strong position on it and rich you
have known me for all those years and
you know that i am not a hot take
person
i don't i don't have hot takes just for
the purposes of having hot takes
but i do feel strongly about this when
you own a business you have to make a
decision as to whether those you employ
particularly someone in a leadership
position
is a good leader and does exercise good
judgment and in my view this is just
another or yet another instance of urban
not exercising good judgment there have
been a number of instances before this
and it was a glaring lack of leadership
i heard you mention uh that mike
lombardi shared with you that he can't
recall a time in his career when a coach
didn't fly home with a team and as i
shared in that athletic piece i can't
recall an instance in which a head coach
didn't fly home with us either now you
know if there was an instance and i'm
simply not remembering it i am confident
it was because of an emergency situation
like a funeral or you know a loved one
who was terminally ill but i really
don't remember an instance
in which a head coach
did not return with the team and a
that's leadership but b to all the
people who said to me oh aim nothing
goes on the plane no excuse me i was on
those planes for almost 30 years and
business
does go on on those planes but again
lack of leadership not to come home with
the team yeah and and you know i i've
been on those planes too and you know
players sometimes go up front to talk to
the coach sometimes the coach goes in
the back certainly if the team's
heartbroken like urban meyer said in the
post game press conference thursday in
cincinnati that his team was that you
know that there there is uh business to
be done or
or
rallies to cry you know like these are
these are things that to be done but so
um
the fact though that he stayed behind
and then the video comes out of what he
was doing while staying behind even
though that wasn't you know we all
assume and and i think correctly so
that's not the reason why he stayed
behind was what we saw on the video
but um you know
even if it was i mean if it was then
that would make a whole different story
out of this but
let's put it together and just say you
know what what you said at the end of
that column is you think that
jacksonville should just swing the axe
right now and don't even wait to see
what's happening i do um and as i said
in that piece um
do as i say not as i do is not
leadership in my view and i want to make
very clear what i endeavored to make
clear in that article and on twitter and
i believe you and i are in accord on
this
i would terminate him not for what he
did when he stayed back that's between
urban and his wife
that's between urban and his family i
would terminate him simply for staying
back because i don't know how you lead a
team
when you're
evidencing glaring lacks of leadership
like that now you know maybe he can
reconstitute himself i do believe in
second chances but and by the way i've
been given second chances in life and
and i worked for a team owner who gave
people second chances but if i
and third chances and fourth chances um
if i owned a business i would have
trouble now after the i think this is
the third time since he's been hired
that i have thought poor judgment poor
judgment
poor judgment and as a business owner do
i want someone in a position of
leadership that i think continues to
exercise poor judgment and my answer to
that is no and you are absolutely right
rich of course as to what goes on on
team planes never did i see and you know
there was never a flight home that i
didn't see our coach walking throughout
that plane and speaking to players
whether we were in a good mood or a bad
mood heartbroken or otherwise meeting
with players speaking with players
sometimes players would approach the
clutch the coach would meet with
trainers and the medical staff and talk
about injuries they'd start talking
about the next week's game plan but more
importantly
that coach came home with his team you
know what let me use this term ride or
die
hmm amy trask here on the rich eisen
show well what you just said uh here's
what might be the loophole in it amy is
the fact that and certainly you with uh
a legal mind as well
um that that
to say that we're firing you we're
terminating you for cause
um not the morals clause and it was
interesting to see shot khan use the
word conduct in his statement
um that that we're firing you for cause
because of this
um that basically his response would be
well i i told the general manager i was
gonna do this and he said okay even
though obviously the command and control
structure of hiring somebody like urban
is you hand him the keys to everything
and he's clearly shown that being handed
the keys he can crash the car
uh but wouldn't wouldn't he be able to
say essentially and that's the ultimate
problem for this is that there's a
command and control structure where the
general manager doesn't tell him that's
a bad idea urban you got it you've got
to take this plane back home
well you're absolutely right to point
that out and i did see urban's comment
in that regard i've not seen anything
from trent so you know there's a lot to
explore there did he say hey i'm staying
back and was he told well look i think
that's a really really really bad idea
but i don't have the authority to tell
you not to go talk to shad i don't know
what the response was was the response
okay sure stay back if that's the case
you're absolutely right there are legal
issues and arguments to be made
associated with that look there's a
dance that may go on here it
if you know if there's a termination
um and and i was teased today when i
said termination someone meant do you
mean said do you mean killing him or
just fire
of course
i'm using the legal word for firing um
but if shad chooses to terminate him to
fire him there's going to be an argument
an arbitration over is money owed
and maybe they can settle that on a
going forward basis maybe urban says all
right you know i'm partly responsible
let's reach a happy medium let's not
have an arbitration but yes all of this
is going to unfold if in fact shaw
decides to move on amy trask here on the
rich eisen show from cbs sports um
former raiders ceo
right here on the show and i i think
just once again because you know i see a
lot of responses from what uh i've been
saying here and what others like
yourself have been saying is like you
know what did he do wrong right what did
he do wrong like again it's none of your
business what he was doing and so on and
so forth and as you stipulated and i i
would agree that is true
it's what it implies in terms of what
everybody can do on this team and what
he as an authority figure can set as
parameters of their conduct and how that
has now been blown to complete
smithereens chris long who's been in
this business for a very long time had a
perfect tweet that encapsulated the
entire thing earlier this week when he
tweeted out that if i'm a veteran player
in jacksonville now i am my own boss is
what he had to say so how does this get
put back together can he win sunday
truly help put all of this back together
based on your knowledge about that
special bond between coach and locker
room amy i'm not sure that special bond
exists in the case of jacksonville i
would posit for you that there is no
special bond right now between urban and
that locker room and i'm not suggesting
that you're suggesting otherwise um look
i think chris's point is is right on on
point um how do you get up in front of a
team now if you're urban let's say
you're going into the bye week how do
you say your team i don't want you to do
anything that's going to bring any shame
on the club i'm a player i'm laughing or
i'm rolling my eyes i want you to stay
out of trouble i don't want to i don't
want video of you floating around the
ether i don't want to see you doing
anything that embarrasses your
organization how do you have one iota of
credibility again i'll point to the
phrase that i used in the athletic piece
what you're saying is do as i say
not as i do and i don't think that's
good leadership and something that you
know you need to focus on
this is a locker room of men
you know very different than college
where all the players are very very
young in an nfl locker room sure you've
got some young players right out of
college we drafted some men who weren't
yet 21 but you also have men well into
their 20s and their 30s and in some
instances beyond that
these are men
how do you do the do as i say not as i
do
you know you ask about what if they win
there's a phrase winning cures
everything i don't believe that i've
never believed that what winning is is a
great deodorant and that's the phrase
i've always used winning is a great
deodorant it takes the smell away from a
lot of things but winning alone doesn't
cure underlying issues it just disguises
it
well and how difficult is it to win if
the trust on that front has been
destroyed or uh
uh or considerably altered amy because i
i mean again it you're mentioning the
bye week which is in two weeks from now
there and and that that's all well and
good but it's just like in the crucible
of a game when adversity hits and the
coach has got to make a call about
whether go for it on fourth down or punt
or kick or what have you call a timeout
or manage the clock or anything that
doubt creeps in as to that person's
again he could be you know as terrific
at that aspect of it as urban has shown
in his years of coaching that one slip
up suddenly that doubt begins to creep
into the mind's eye of a player during
the the action of a game that's where i
would also be concerned if i'm shot con
and keep a very keen eye on that
sideline and the field on sunday an
interesting point you raise and i don't
know that i would look so much to
players questioning an x's and o call
although your point is very interesting
what i would look to is is this a coach
and i'll use a euphemism that players
want to run through a wall
for in other words i've seen coaches
during my career where players are going
to just do absolutely anything and
everything they can to run through that
proverbial wall and i've seen instances
in which it's like yeah not so much so
you know i believe football more than
many other sports is a game in which
emotion
plays a tremendous role it is a game in
which momentum
born of emotion and which creates
emotion
plays a tremendous role is that someone
on the sideline for whom those players
are going to say yeah i'm going to run
through a wall for you last one for you
amy trash before i let you go on this on
this thursday um based on your knowledge
of institutional knowledge of the nfl
and competition committee and the way
coaches think and what you might know
about what's going on in the nfl right
now who ordered the code red on
celebrations with the taunting um with
the taunting emphasis who ordered the
code red that's a great question because
a number of coaches have spoken out in
support of the rule i'm sure there's
also phone calls going around the league
saying hey could you talk out in support
of the rule could you give a little
shout out to the rule um you know i
believe it emanated from the competition
committee but the way committees work
and the league office works the league
office and committees work hand in hand
and i don't mean that in a negative way
but when you want to make a rule change
or you want to put a rule up for vote
you go to the league office then you go
to a committee then you go back to the
league office then you go back to a
committee so i'm sure a lot of people
were involved in that i love your use of
the expression code red that's great and
you know my issue is as follows do i
believe that people should do things
that cross a certain line of course not
but there's no way you can expect a
player to play with emotion we always
say we want to see our players play with
emotion well you know what when you play
with emotion emotion pours through so
you know
it was said in a supreme court decision
of obscenity
i know it when i see it and i think when
it comes to
i think that was justice potter stewart
gosh that was just a flashback from law
school um i know it when i see it i'll
say the same thing of taunting we know
it when we see it and let's not go too
far in calling things taunting i know
darren waller
was not taunting just because he spiked
it on the bench i mean that was not a
taunt and it's so obvious it was not a
taunt and you know obviously i have the
benefit of you know
sitting on my couch and seeing that and
you know
in the in the whole you know caught up
in in everything a referee might just
throw a flag like but that was
ridiculous that's not a taunt he was not
taunting he was playing with emotion
like what i said the same thing at the
time of course you probably said it to
your audience the next day i just said
it to my husband but i said that wasn't
a taunt he didn't do it in someone's
face he didn't do it to
taunt someone to rub anything in he was
excited he didn't put that ball near
anyone i agree with you i know
all right amy thanks very much i always
appreciate catching up with you i always
appreciate the opportunity to do so well
no uh and and hi that's how i'll say
that at the time
okay we'll chat soon that's uh that's
that's amy trask amy trask i follow her
on twitter you should as well
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here